for for all the mayo head of course i
have to go and consult
one of the cow farms yeah well i mean i
have to consult basically the man the
man who bret who bred her
uh and that's of course jj stoner uh
let's see here
let's get him on hey jj what's up fellow
zombie viking squad members
yeah zombie viking squad the
i turned the screen on do you see it
circle circle no hold on let me call let
me hang up call back
okay it's uh we gotta come up
[Music]
let's see if it works this time right
that's so much better
oh there goes okay we're good yeah i'm
good
i know disc shut up with your discord
[ __ ] this car is better and i have a
sound board so
yeah well that's part of the reason
we're not on dis discord i know because
you're scared of my soundboard and you
have a soundboard we could have
soundboard wars
uh excuse me hold on hold on this is
royce heyman
royce just said okay if you keep coming
with him i'm gonna help bali make
[ __ ] all over
hey [ __ ] you that's the best mod in that
game right now it is
all right so mayo head um
yeah right we last left off with mayo
head
she made a well we were part one of the
video she made a video talking about us
and
aids for some reason um
oh the lord goes deep man i've i've been
getting a lot of comments from people
that
never really watch a show but that know
her and
saying like she's an attention [ __ ] to
half the stuff she's saying is lies
so i'm really trying to actually break
this down to see what's real you know
i did get some people so she'll enjoy
this then you're welcome
oh yeah i got some people that also said
that uh
making being mad at me saying oh what do
you do make fun of poor people i'm like
i don't make fun of poor people i make
fun of [ __ ] crazy people there is a
[ __ ] difference
i make fun of terrible people how about
that so
uh this is her second video of the of
course it was a fat hairy men laughing
at me is nothing new
so uh let's uh that's the title of the
video that's what it says
so let's check it out okay so i wound up
going back to sleep after i made those
videos
um which is what i do when i'm
having a real hard time i i tend to just
sleep a whole lot you know that's
you know when you're homeless and you
have no money that's a good use of your
time
just sleep it off she's out there rising
and grinding huh
can she's not hunting for those cans
very well yeah
prove all the haters wrong take a 16
hour nap
this week was already going to be kind
of hard for me
because my birthday is coming up and
it's it's hard
you know ev every year it's hard for me
and
i just i i sleep through it i push
past it sleeping through it
is the opposite of pushing past it
yeah it's tapping out well not fully
committing how about we put it that way
you know but this year knowing that
someone has a good point
she looks very cyberpunk
glitchy and [ __ ] up sure yes you're
right there's this group of
men out there mocking me and laughing at
me and
who are these people they sound terrible
those guys are [ __ ]
i for one disavow these people the
leader
their leader is fat and bearded wow
that's really mean thing to say about jj
don't forget bald i have hair wanting me
to hurt myself
it uh it doesn't make things any easier
all right hold on hold on hold on hey
hold on
we never said to hurt yourself lady this
is the point and i tried to pick up the
people that that really don't
apparently she's [ __ ] other people
over not once did
any of us ever do even in
slightly imply that you should hurt
yourself or do anything like that
yourself
you're this is the problem you're
already hurting your own case nobody
said that
nobody ever said that in fact i wanted
to make more content
yeah i don't want you to hurt yourself i
want you to have a prosperous life are
you kidding me
i mean i want you to stop hurting ducks
but i don't want you to stop hurting
yourself
i i don't i don't know what's happening
you're putting your entire homeless life
on youtube
and expecting no one to respond or
comment about it
he commented on my channel you're
welcome that i did do
i did do that i will be honest with you
i will uh put that out there i i did do
that
that guy's an [ __ ] i can't believe we
did that it wasn't me it was that dave
wave radio guy
the dave way yeah if the video was
thanking him for his hatefulness
i don't i don't know i don't know maybe
he made it up just like you just made up
that we want you hurt
yeah i mean i said thank you because
apparently you like attention
you know i can't be mad at the guy
because this is i don't you seem pretty
mad
his job right i mean i would say
pissy miffed yeah you know a little
cranky how about cranky but she just
took a nap for 16 hours actually
yeah she's still tired but you know
i can't be mad at the guy because this
is his job
right it's his job
to laugh at people like me
well yes at least i have a job
sure enough but she's not doing her job
which is to be the world's recycling so
i can just throw my cans on the ground
yeah she'll pick him up
and she'll yell at people at a fake dog
bite it's amazing
people that his viewers
he's like 7 000 viewers and his whole
job is to just
watch the videos they show him first off
it's 7610.
and make fun of these people that are
thinking i can't wait till she sees the
rotc girth coming at her
this is just a [ __ ] appetizer this is
the the b
show what the [ __ ] are you talking about
this isn't even anything it's
just farting around we're farting around
over here not as mentally strong or as
financially well-off as them
we think we're rich because we're not
i'm not
yeah i'm not i'm lucky with what i have
and i appreciate it but [ __ ] man
i don't have a leg miss yeah and i'm
missing an
eye so i think i'm a little worse off
than you have you seen his forehead holy
[ __ ] he's got to lug that [ __ ] thing
around all day
a lot of weight it is it's a lot of
weight like
i have strong neck muscles guys yeah
some sucking dick
i set myself up for that oh yeah i don't
need softballs but but i'll take
yeah his the last time i saw a forehead
that big it was answering the door for
the
adams family
mean to each other here too [ __ ] it so
don't worry about it i don't know if
you're getting so upset we're actually
meaner to each other
listen have you heard his squeaky voice
ma'am yeah come on seriously have you
seen my [ __ ] forehead
yeah sometimes when i get so high
pitched only dogs and superman could
hear me
so [ __ ] relaxed you've seen my face
come on yeah
and jj has blood cancer also known as
aids come on
blood cancer is the homelessness of
cancers yes it's the one that's just
[ __ ] slow
long painful yes
see what i mean so come on take a joke
let's keep going close to me the thought
that a bunch of men are just sitting
around
mocking me hey hey hey
hey we're also sitting around playing
video games and stuff we're not just
mocking you and i identify as a trans
black woman so [ __ ]
yeah seriously for the record i'm
shirtless so yeah so there you go guys
she [ __ ] who cares
calling me ugly
not that i care because i'm genuinely
over relationship she makes three 20
minute videos but she doesn't
care what were the hold on hold on what
relationships things we're trying to
[ __ ] her
no one's trying to have sex with you
well i could speak for us three we have
a lot of weirdos in the chat but
no none of us are well i mean ag doesn't
like left and right so much so maybe he
needs it
hey g go out there and fix this thing
come on take one for the team yeah go
[ __ ] give it
i wouldn't [ __ ] her with your dick give
her the old peg leg
yeah i don't care if i ever the angry
pirate
i have another relationship i don't care
if i die alone but i still don't want to
be made fun of
nobody does i mean i don't care
i don't want to man yeah i shouldn't
really care be honest with you you also
need to get a
you don't get to control who makes fun
of you miss i don't care if you make fun
of me
you know i met one of these men once
like not literally
oh jj has a secret like jj for the whole
time
jj have you been sleeping with her no
i'm all the way over here she's over
there how's it possible my dick isn't
that big i mean
wait she's she's in california a.g
have you been [ __ ] her no i'm getting
moved away
from that area yes i shove my forehead
in her snooze
pretty sure but just after meemaw passed
i was
trying to find somebody to live with
you know um get myself off of the street
and a man he responded to my craigslist
ad
this story no story no good story ever
starts with he responded to my
craigslist dad
no positive story in the history has
ever started that way
i i need to see that craigslist ad
please it's never been
he responded to my craigslist ad and now
i'm a millionaire
instead now it's i have aids yeah he
responded to my craigslist out of
something
here in one of those a e reenactions
when they [ __ ] kill somebody
hold on jj we missed the whole point
that she started off in florida
damn so what i didn't [ __ ] don't
don't put that [ __ ] thing on me
i like white women he drove like
three hours to come and pick me up
and he took me back home with him
and he made me watch
like two or three hours of
hate videos was this merch
it was sounds like me because honestly
we might all be wrong it might just be
if you hate videos
then it was probably mark was merc
showing you his private stash of hate
videos
just hate videos i mean
[Music]
like he kept showing me videos of judy
garland doing blackface
so it was you jesus it might have been
me i might have disassociated
making them watch black guys work out on
british tv shows
[ __ ] something about the outpost he
kept saying he wanted to take me to the
outpost he kept showing me the video of
some guy named thomas who worked at a
grocery store
i don't know what this guy was all about
back in the day there was some guy named
kurt he was on a locomotive
[ __ ] kid
it was horrifying there's something
who's this guy named ben he keeps going
he kept borrowing tarot card readers
there's some guy named carlos navarro
black bean
oh [ __ ] right
so maybe it was me guys i apologize then
he was on this youtube channels where
these
men would just go on and on for hours
about like how women
are weaker than me okay so definitely
was marsh
yeah this is sounding like marsh this
sounded more and more like merch guys
and like oh it was got it was it was
insanity it was
like i can't even remember it all right
now
because you're making it up as you go
along because he was
because he [ __ ] her after
chloroforming seriously
because i wound up getting extremely
stoned
yeah i'm with you nice maybe it was jj
though the whole time now listen no guys
was this all was this all of us though
because if you think about it extremely
stoned
[ __ ] hateful content like this might
just be all of us that did this to her
she was she's like she's a gang stalked
gang raped victim yeah
trying to sleep in the living room
because i didn't want to be in the same
room as him because he was such an
[ __ ] but you but you definitely did
smoke his weed right
it was so gross and i was thinking like
is this really
does this work for you like dude he was
hoping you'd suck his dick
yeah you know the working part of the
road
well the working part is he picked you
up and you're homeless
and offered you a place to sleep on his
[ __ ] dick and smoked you out come on
now be grateful [ __ ]
you really get women to like you by
bringing them back home
and showing them videos of other men
talking about
why women are weaker and
dependent on men and i don't know man it
works like 70 percent of the time
it sounds like she's seen rotc i it
really does
like these videos were completely
like going off and saying that women
can't have jobs and can't do like normal
things we're all [ __ ] and [ __ ] and
sex is the only thing we're good for
hey lady you said it not me
jj i butted heads i'm sorry it was there
that's the correct response you said it
not me was it the nick fuentes video
she might have been one hey hey nick
fuentes here
i'm sitting in my booster chair trying
to get america first
barefoot and pregnant that's where a
woman's supposed to be no no i've never
said that you're allowed to have
did shoes the kitchen was a possibility
yeah
and just oh god i understood why the man
was single and trying to find somebody
on craigslist
and i mean but you accepted the ad
who use craig who uses craigslist like a
dating site and not for just getting a
prostitute serial killers
hobos hobos hobos and serial killers
that's right sam
sam are you on craigslist that's her
target audience
coming from somebody that was single and
trying to find somebody on craigslist
right
this isn't
i love when she explains something and
then explains the reason and then still
doesn't understand it yep
so now it just feels like like that
group
that that woman hating group
no ma'am that i was introduced to back
then
it just feels like they've been
introduced to me and now they're going
to be making fun of me
and i kind of i i expected it i said the
other day that video that i made was
going to piss off men
let me tell you there's a lot of things
that have happened
but you haven't pissed any of us off no
none of us have gotten any anger out of
excitement yes
[ __ ] laughter of course but no one's
pissed
i've been giggling like a school girl
for months watching this chicks videos
yeah
so no one's making no one's angry i
didn't mean to
i was joking i know you all aren't birds
that are true
so we're we're also joking
we're also joking i mean not about the
you not ever working or anything or
not about the women shouldn't vote thing
we're serious about that but the other
stuff we're joking
like killing ducks and wearing uh
pendulum or whatever that [ __ ] thing
is on your next
steve carlesi album [ __ ] swinging
the other way by the way r.i.p today's
the anniversary
of his number [ __ ] of his death yeah
damn
yeah opie okay in the chat opie opie
killed him a legend oh
man you know what legislation is there
yeah i said allegedly
i said allegations okay good attracted
to shiny objects
but i'm not allowed to joke and so now a
bunch of
men you are allowed to tell a joke
stupid
yeah come on do it
hey hey i challenge you mary i know
you're going to watch this can you make
a stand-up routine and just be funny
i dare you dress like paula poundstone
jk
women are funny jj women are funny no
yeah [ __ ] they're hilarious when
they're not trying to be
are offended and now a bunch of men are
sitting back
sharing videos of me and laughing
and feeling all powerful and strong
because they took down that crazy lady
no first she's trying to turn us into
this is the thing that she doesn't
understand
how i could just kill a man but also the
thing she doesn't understand is
this isn't a sexism thing okay
we just it's a stupid thing yeah we've
made fun of i make probably fun of more
men than women as a matter of fact when
i'm thinking about it
you know i'm [ __ ] dating well is he a
man i guess
but yeah [ __ ] dashing the psychic
yeah go down the list man
in my bed jerking off to mexicans
exactly didn't do anything to them
they really knocked her off her pedestal
holy no no no no you would have to own a
pedestal to be knocked off of it
this ain't american gladiators someone
just pointed out that she looks like
maisie williams from game of thrones
arya stark
she looks like wrecked arya stark i mean
she looks like a ps1
[ __ ] rendering of her i guess i like
to hank his area
hanky's area works nathan lane is the
other one that [ __ ] frozen calls her
nathan azaria good job guys
thanks yeah good job guys um
well this is good because at least now
she got over it and oh wait there's
another video
uh the necklace moved
it moved to the it's a different
necklace it's the same but it shifted a
little
well no the necklace the pendant didn't
the necklace did
let's uh let's see part two of listen
guys this is gonna be an easy breezy one
this one this video is only
48 minutes long and you know the sad
thing is
this one cranks out so much there's
three videos over the weekend that we
can also cover
i know i know we're not gonna get
through this i'm not gonna play all 48
minutes i'm going to skip around
you know what it would be almost awesome
if we had like a [ __ ] intern that
wasn't drinking and playing video games
all weekend
wouldn't it be [ __ ] nice
yeah that's why you're here you're the
one who brings little cows do you know
do you know anybody yeah he brings the
cows
they're on the cliff [ __ ] i'm not gonna
clip up other people's content my job is
to
try and clip up their stuff where's his
content now you're his [ __ ] do his
bidding
i'm not even hey i don't i don't i don't
like this is this this is this is really
guys you're please follow champ jump
jump [ __ ] can he has one leg i
know it's gonna be funny because he only
has one leg jump
[ __ ] old pogo stick over here you're
gonna [ __ ] do anything
that's a pogo stick i think i should
replace it with the pogo's no
he should replace it the cyber cyberpunk
jump in that game all right let's focus
[Laughter]
see miss they make fun of me a lot more
stop your whining
oh [ __ ] i cry myself to sleep all every
night
okay here we go i'm focused guys
are we focusing no okay
jj take a hit come on we need you to
focus i'll
all right take take a roof hit
all right it's raining so i'm not going
outside all right here we go
all right responding to dave wave
dave wave part two
okay so sorry about that that was my
therapist
calling probably a good thing since i
was halfway through
this video how the [ __ ] does a homeless
person afford a [ __ ] therapist
she doesn't the state pays for it oh
it's california oh so
so you pay for it yes okay this is your
fault you're paid for
i don't i have to how am i not you have
no choice
taxes man yo
um what was i about to say the stand was
sophie's situation
no i was not talking about the people in
my head when i was talking about the
people that got involved in that
situation
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] we have elmo number one ladies
and gentlemen that was a good one
people in my head holy [ __ ]
no context so he does not know this stan
was sophie
was a facebook group sophie was
a little girl who was possibly being
abused by her
mother and stepfather her father
filmed her freaking out about it yeah
we know what does this have to do with
anything oh my god
oh my god what is up with the underbite
don't look at her teeth royce that's all
i could see that's all i can look at now
or her fingernails looks like a pug
i can't hear it am i saying something i
don't know
you know when when i was in my breakdown
stage i did feel like giving up on all
of it
oh she's breaking down okay good good
good
my senses and [ __ ] inception man back
to my doctor and go back on my
medication
cool my doctor and my therapist
they beat me in the outpatient room
well let me take a shower my doctor used
to be a boxer
it's been three months i can smell my
butthole
that i do not feel like i'm being
treated like a human being
i'm i'm a man i'm not an
animal
[Laughter]
it's been one week since you looked at
me
three months since i took a shower
since i've had a shower jj
you nailed it i spoiled it you nailed it
what yes sir this is an onion
hey jj those two guys talking sound
pretty cool
yeah [ __ ] they're still [ __ ] they
[ __ ] still suck
as soon as you and worse and worse and
so
how is she not at a shower in a month
dude she's been in her section 8 housing
and she still probably hasn't showered
why is dingo southern elmo yelling at
this lady
[Laughter]
dingo elmo that's the name of our show
dingo elmo there's a reason why
okay so
saying that i'm in my section all right
dayton can you [ __ ] stop
rubbing the microphone with sun chips
and i'm still not showering
is that's just mean
are you showering but are you showering
you can say it's mean but are you
showering
honestly you know um yes
i was taking baths with that hole in my
ceiling
i was cleaning out ceiling dust out of
my tub every day so i could get a bath
when the you know
if this okay first off
ceiling dust so you're hitting shifts
ceiling dust too bad it's not as best as
it might be ceiling dust may be one of
my new favorite things in the world
well i mean there is lord of that she
had a hole over top of her
her tub oh dude some people call that a
[ __ ]
people a sunroof or i mean a water leak
yeah i mean
i was grateful i've been so thankful to
be able to get showers every day here
like y'all don't even get it and steve
says
dingle elmo open for non-point at zeta
fest once
actually it was prior fest i think it
was okay yeah it was it was [ __ ] they
were great though
they were [ __ ] scary but power faces
look for a little florida humor for you
guys only florida people get this show
yeah i live there two years so i get it
long enough in her videos
the person that lives above her has a
leak
so that guy needs to blow his [ __ ]
nose jesus you nasally
oh sorry jesus christ these guys i'm
sorry
all right it's your fault because you we
we get spicy at night yes
i got here and i went through all of
that
hell with the police trying just to get
here
just to find out that i still can't get
it forgot
the stream is she's me is she making
herself cry
dude if she comments on this video it's
gonna be awesome
oh my god can you imagine because i want
i really want to see how deep we could
go how many
how many levels of inception we could
get it's gonna turn into a [ __ ]
papa bad yeah
just pull up the day wave right now and
it'll be royce royce
it's gonna be like a salvador dali
experimental painting
okay so um this
is steve's killing it ceiling dust is a
classic sawyer brown song
this is ceiling dust
before they got me on the zoloft
which is antidepressant i was much like
mike tyson she has to be on the zoloft
to stop her from killing y'all
well i could tell you right now i know
of about five or six different medicines
she needs to be on besides olaf
then he's stronger than that lady
lithium
talk to your health care provider by the
way we're not we don't we don't give out
medical advice
i don't wish you harm i wish you nothing
but the best in your future endeavors
you deserve the best you deserve fancy
feast
and dukes don't forget dudes duke's mayo
and fancy feast
with depression and [ __ ] i got
depression
times um i don't know if this is for
everybody but for me
when i get really depressed what i do to
keep myself alive
is i set goals you know i
i tell myself you know um it's play as
much snes as humanly possible
today today i'm going to blame this many
men for all my problems
today i'm going to smoke eight balls and
do nothing
yeah she's basically 50 cent many men
wish death upon me
ceiling dust in my eyes and i can't see
men trying to take my shower away
hey guys we still do 50 cent references
here that's the kind of show we rock
it's bad right now but i'm going to get
paid next week or i'm going to get a
shower
next week and i will just continuously
remind myself of that one good
thing that is coming up and so
you know i'll get to this point where i
just want to [ __ ] die
and not deal with it anymore and i'll
just tell myself no
you're going to be able to get a shower
in two days if you
someone's pointing out and this is
actually like if you go like why don't
you just [ __ ] sign up for
planet fitness it's like nine bucks a
month and they have showers
and you get free pizza on fridays right
she won't have man shoulders
that's true die now you'll die stinking
you won't be able to get that shower so
when i showed up
why don't i take you out back and hose
you off like a naughty cocker spaniel
[Music]
and i was denied that shower it did mean
a lot
and it wasn't just because i i was
stinking and wanted a shower
i think that was on the equipment
outcast album i'm pretty sure stanking
and wanting a shower
shaking like a polaroid sorry
it was because i was going through a bad
depression
and i had hung all of my hopes
on getting that shower yeah that's
called setting yourself up for failure
yeah and also
way to have a high bar yeah
just find someone's yard and wash off in
their house
go take a mcdonald's shower and it was
taken away i hope well it is a hobo
shower yeah
it's a hobo birdbath but have fun
laughing at it
okay thank you as a matter of fact if
you want to get
if you're by the beach i mean you could
just go to one of the beach showers
right
or she could just go in the [ __ ]
ocean yeah go in the ocean
puddle of water over there why is her
thumb so black
well because she's been she's been
gaming so hard
well people want to steal that i don't
know if i want to anymore
real funny stuff right yes yes
they don't care that it'll be another
month
they don't i love reading the comments
on the screen from the last video though
she looks like nathan lane this is why i
stay in a closet
this might not be over then oh hey kyla
that's called calling out [ __ ] things
on your soundboard something that never
happens on your show
sorry three months
without a shower they don't care
they don't remind me as a person
he's laughing at me saying it could be
three months i first off i didn't laugh
did you see me laugh
no you said i didn't laugh i was
actually in shock
i laughed i don't care i have no shame
no no no i mean i'm sure i laughed at
some other point but my point is in this
specific situation i didn't laugh i'd
like to remind y'all i went five
but before i actually got a shower it
was september
five months without a shower jesus
christ this is a terrible earth winning
fire song
that [ __ ] smell do you remember
do you remember to wash your [ __ ] in
september
it smells like rotten cheese
i will no longer be taking medication
i went back you know who else didn't
have a [ __ ]
work regular working shower ted
kaczynski and he was great
good at math and predicting the future
well he's right yeah whatever
i can't i can't hear i'm hear what this
handsome fella saying
um was pet friendly so some of the
people had dogs that they didn't clean
up after
i walked multiple times i would walk out
and see dog [ __ ] just laying in the
hallway
so pick it up welcome to l.a yeah i
could don't live in l.a don't
actually hope you have that at the other
place
[ __ ] just follows you everywhere to live
and die in
l.a a place with pee
oh yeah at least he has a
appropriate response to that appropriate
appropriate
[ __ ]
it was there for two days
i told you this was a cherry i've been
holding on to this one for a while and
i'm like man
whoever gets this is gonna be a [ __ ]
a goddamn camaro of a [ __ ] train
wreck here
she did not like that i don't think jj i
don't think she did
i'm pretty sure she doesn't like me it's
okay hi
mary so here's that
um
i guess i'd just like to ask what is it
that makes me not a human being
no one said that who's who said you
weren't a human being
never said that she's not wrong she's
imposing herself feelings
upon us i guess that's how she feels
i fully understand that you're a human
being but you're also
a stupid human being so i'm recognizing
that you're a human
but you're exceptionally dumb at least
she's not murdering ducks
oh wait i have a story to tell you oh no
oh no later steve thanks for hanging out
bud
um can you can you answer that for me
what is it that makes me so much
different
from you aside from the facial hair
iq job
having a home a shower a
truck i mean what really makes them
better
don't keep going a penis yeah to penises
deodorant yeah it's a good point
deodorant yeah
i don't have condiments in my head nail
clippers
that's a good one nail clippers yes yes
yes
more than one shitty necklace should we
keep going
i haven't i have a next-gen console not
an snes
uh i have a super powered pc beast
yeah a camera that isn't his cell phone
oh that's a good point yeah a neck a
hellraiser figure
goals i mean three start looking around
the room
three different streaming services that
i pay for
mr burns pop yes should we keep going
because somebody says
common sense ck goes i don't know common
sense
stupid prick says a loving family a
a wife who loves him i mean look my
family's dead soon
that's sad um let's play let's play
take let's let's get get to somebody's
donation i'm sure people have some
comments
sorry royce moneybags poor person
oppressor lopez
hey
how on earth does she always manage to
explain her awful decisions
and the explanation is actually more
vile than the actual act
no one uses craigslist for dating no one
craig's list is for selling items off
the books
yeah exactly in prostitutes
you guys are talking a lot of [ __ ] but
her cover tracks are fire shake it like
an empty
bottle of shampoo you pooped in the
shower it wasn't me
hey hey dead birds
i'll read it because she read it wrong
you guys are taking a lot talking a lot
of [ __ ] but her cover tracks are fire
shake it like an empty champ bottle of
shampoo
who pooped in the shower parentheses it
wasn't me
and the last sign was hey hey y'all dead
birds
um
i haven't heard the shaggy reference on
the date wave episode yet such a lovely
personality
by choice i'm single by choice
thank you no no no one's single by
choice by the way those people are
called liars
merch it's not by choice it's because of
his charming personality
[Laughter]
she needs to learn how to normalize
audio it's really well she's doing it
off her phone but man what do you expect
i'm i here we go oh [ __ ]
that's not saying cystic spam
grenades you don't throw rice at them
oh no of course not any birds because it
expands in their stomach
okay all right so here we go point out
i'm gonna point out that this man is
aware
that dry rice expands
in the bird's stomach and you're not
supposed to feed them dried rice
i did not feed them uncooked rice
multiple times i have said the rice was
cooked the rice was cooked specifically
for the birds
i went back i came back to the apartment
i cooked the rice
mayo head chef to the birds
cooled it down i took it out there to
them
the fact that y'all are insisting but if
you're like homeless and you don't have
food
are you worried about the birds yeah why
are you giving your rice away to birds
well she gives her money away too so
that i've killed these birds
it's different birds that i filmed that
were alive it's
it's hurtful it's [ __ ] i don't think
she understands how bits work
like it doesn't look i fully understand
that you did the thing the correct way
but it is so much funnier to insinuate
that you did it the wrong way
duck killer yeah kitty said you forgot
the track not so fresh
not so clean
oh [ __ ] and also bombs in my bathroom
and it's stupid because he just said
himself
that it's he called you stupid bud
you've made exactly how much you made at
that point in time as you have
oh it's so weird look at that
consistency
this is crazy we're like we're we're
look at this is like
beautiful cooked rice you shouldn't feed
birds because it expands in their
stomach and i made a video
saying why you shouldn't feed birds
uncooked rice
going without context he wouldn't know
that he thinks i'm just going out there
throwing
uncooked rice at the birds tomorrow
she's gonna start feeding the bird's
hand grenades
which is not cool and i made a video
expressly
malevolent centered kills my local birds
really love alka-seltzer
they have upset tummies from all the
rice see if she'll see if she'll do that
don't they'll [ __ ] all over the place
stating that that's not cool
mike tesla says i believe the term is
self-partnered yes you saw parker
everyone knows did she kill ducks no
no
she doesn't kill ducks okay stop saying
she does all right
i'm gonna say right around here
uh there it is what that was having
kid problems and they had their problems
you're homeless
so she sent 100 oh here's a good time to
remind everybody that megan schwartz
still owes me a hundred dollars
yeah i don't know who this megan
schwartz is but she sounds like a lovely
lady
like like i said that you have to stay
on top of this one because she
evolved so fast there's already another
video about this
so making sure to owes her a hundred
dollars why is a homeless person lending
out money
because she got her stimulus i think she
got her stimulus
and then tried to help her out because
of her kids with the understanding that
she was gonna get the hundred when the
immigrant mexican
uh got her money back by the way it's
megan schwartz merkel do you see
something happening here
yeah this is the name that this lady
used to scam the money out of her is
megan schwartz merkel
hmm does that ring a bell well yeah
she's the prime minister of germany
bingo why would the prime minister of
germany need a hundred dollars from the
mayo head i don't know she did crash
that economy pretty bad
all right fair enough yeah the world did
so
fair enough and yes
i am homeless and still helping
people and still feel okay but see this
is this is
this is let me give you some free advice
here okay since you're i know you can't
afford to pay me
um free advice here if you're homeless
and you're in a bad situation stop
helping other people
help yourself charity is for people that
can afford charity
she doesn't look at it as real money
because all of it's given to her by the
state that's a good point it's just play
money for her
yeah and same with her ebt card and
everything else her food stamps
you know she's a [ __ ] welfare queen
that's all she is
somebody one of my friends told me once
at one point was homeless at one point
he told me um he's like yeah you know
like i i was homeless and i had my last
20
and you know what i did with that last
20 was i gave it to this homeless guy on
the street and i called him a
[ __ ] [ __ ] for a year i'm like
you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're homeless you're the one that
needs the [ __ ] money don't give away
your money if you're [ __ ] homeless
i have a home and i don't give away
money yeah [ __ ] jj's basically jewish
i am not animals because i am a human
being
she did it she did the elephant man line
i can't be
i'm i am unclipped sir fair enough
regardless of what you think i am
i am whatever you say i am
if i wasn't then why would i say i am
yes with the implication that she was
gonna get it back with that
uh undocumented immigrant right there
six hundred dollars
oh now i'm junior stoner nice
so i did get that paid though cool
good for you thank you i guess thanks
these are the people that they shouldn't
give the fourteen hundred dollars to
you don't get it yeah because they
wasted like
oh we people all need this money people
need this money but you give them money
and then they use it [ __ ]
for super nintendo's to murder ducks and
to give it away to megan merkel
gamestop seriously
um there is a reason that i ask for
specific items that i need
and that like mayonnaise a shower
probably a douche yeah that [ __ ]
crusty bag
microwaves the reason is because
a lot of people don't feel comfortable
just giving a homeless person money
because they because of people like you
you're the reason people don't feel
comfortable giving homeless people money
because look at what you do with it
the guy holding the sign that says i'm
really bad off and i need a drink i'll
give him money yeah
at least they're being honest but you're
you're [ __ ] the sob stories and then
you're
and then you're [ __ ] playing star fox
well it'll be spent on drugs homeless
means drug addict
homeless doesn't well in a lot of cases
homeless doesn't mean drug addict
but yeah sometimes and sometimes
homeless means mentally ill and
sometimes
people hit a rough time but you waste
your [ __ ]
and why would i keep giving money to
somebody that's going to give it to
somebody else
um if you tell somebody that you need a
blanket
and they're able to physically give you
a blanket
they're more willing to give you that
blanket
than they are to give you the thirty
dollars it would cost to go buy that
blanket
[ __ ] expensive ass blanket oh [ __ ]
what if she heard a yarn like you
couldn't knit your blanket
shout out to maureen what is your
blanket made out of mink
you know get in touch
yeah people are more willing to spend
fifty dollars on something online to
send which is
where her way of saying online
actual product then they are to send me
20
in cash to go and buy the product myself
at a at a thrift store because of the
homeless
stereotype they can't get past even
though so
it's not a stereotype when you see it
happening
in front of you yes you're doing it the
only thing i'm stereotyping
is that her neck smells like rotted milk
no that's that you're smelling your
vagina all the way up at her neck bro
the whole smell this the smells [ __ ]
terrible the smell smells like
usually smells like a [ __ ] taco bell
dumpster
still you know that homeless thing it
sticks in their mind and they just can't
bring themselves to give me a
large amount of money i solved it
dayton wants a strong woman yes
this is dayton's strong woman this is
perfect remember dayton said he did want
a strong woman that's going to protect
him and she can move into the house
this is amazing i feel bad for the
parents that were setting this up but
we got this i get it but at this point
dana will have a strong woman type to
protect him
from the beatings and then she'll be
able to i don't know eat his skin flakes
well let's be honest she needs a fashion
update so he'll help her with that
so i tell people what i need
they send it to me i don't have to deal
as much
with people just saying well she's just
going to spend it on drugs
how am i going to spend curtains on
drugs i mean look
lady i don't care okay i'm happy for you
that you're get that you have supporters
that are trying to help you all right i
have people that try and help us and me
and everybody
that's a very nice aids thing well yeah
some of them will give you aids if you
aren't you know no no i mean people are
trying to help you because of your age
no i don't have aids it's cancer
forehead guy um
but i just i don't understand this
implication that we have sat here and
said that she needs to do this and you
know in minecraft and that we
we're mad that she makes things no one
has said that lady
just i got
that's a drug come on no
you're right jj she's focusing on the
wrong things
yeah being a victim that's her drug you
being homeless
is not the reason that we're goofing on
you you get that right
it's you putting mayonnaise in your head
that's the reason
okay
oh yes so uh yes yes real quick because
he's saying don't look at her teeth
i'm aware jj who said that who said that
was that you
he's the [ __ ] [ __ ] who said
whoever said that it was probably a.g
that said that
did you say don't look at her yeah don't
look at her
no jj said don't look at her teeth i
said she looks like a pug okay
don't look at her fingernails all right
um
but i think it's important to
acknowledge that i've never been
to a dentist there's the problem well we
know
the big big book of british smiles we
get it
you know look this is shitty teeth on
shitty teeth violence i have shitty
teeth too no i don't have great teeth
either
she has no water go ahead sorry because
i can't afford to go to a [ __ ]
dentist that's why
but she can she's mooching the
california system and they give them
dental
i know jesus christ they give them
dental they get den they get [ __ ]
everything they get dental medical eye
optometry she could literally walk into
a dentist
have him [ __ ] rip those [ __ ] out
and put in some fakies yeah but that
death is going to kill himself imagine
putting your fingers in that mouth
yeah parents didn't take us to the
dentist when we were children
um the only time i ever saw a dentist
was when i got my wisdom teeth out
so i've never had anything done
to my teeth i'm impressed that i have
teeth in my mouth at all
so [ __ ] makes two of us
[ __ ] at me about the condition no one's
bitching at you
this is the thing with her man who's
bitching at her
no one's bitching at you it's the voices
in her head
they're they're yelling at her get a job
get a job
oh you won't wash your [ __ ] so get a
job get a job and all she hears is like
buy more mayonnaise
put it in my head murder ducks
mostly all still intact hair dye
yeah [ __ ] you do you need hair dye is
that is that do you need that to live
and that's a whole lot better than a lot
of other homeless people
oh and also one more thing i'm fully
aware i used
too much mayonnaise
look at least she admitted it yeah hey
we finally come to an agreement
everybody clap crew
[ __ ] her too much mayo in her
homeless lettuce and tomato sandwich she
made
um i didn't know how much to use because
i had never done this before but i did
intentionally use too much
for comedic value oh guys
i'm doing we're so we're so stupid she
was doing a bit
we're so dumb if anything out of this
can go viral
we need to make the mayonnaise head
challenge
i'm telling y'all she's moving up to
rotc very soon trust me i'm just working
everything out i i have
i have kitties working on time stamps
for me and stuff we're really gonna
we're gonna have a we're gonna have this
all streamlined
that's a g's job but why would he do it
ag's two ag's too busy just be being uh
being a pirate
yeah and you know doing the whole
clip channel i i know right
it's amazing i keep talking i keep sir i
keep telling aj not to [ __ ] censor
stuff and he keeps doing it
[ __ ] you i'm kidding but people would be
so mad that i said that
yeah they're gonna change which words am
i not supposed to say can you tell me
roy
well yeah any words that we say we're
playing valheim
or trying to take your channels
we're trying to take your channel down
on d live yeah seriously
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um dukes was like three dollars a bottle
i am
i can't i cannot afford to buy high
priced mayonnaise to pour on my head
i can't i can't i can't i'm done i'm
tapping i'm tapping i'm tapping
okay i'm dabbing i'm tapping
i can't who is cheaper by the way
did she i can't afford to spend extra
money
to put the good mayonnaise on my head i
can't i'm losing it
number two
okay i'm all right i'm all right
deep breath i'm good i'm good i'm good
troopers
i just received new orders thank you
mike
oh [ __ ] god damn man
holy [ __ ] next one come on
[Music]
i was without heat and power for four
days during the texas snowpocalypse but
day wave and the
boys at the outpost kept me going thanks
for the show
thank you sir
little known fact she also goes to dog
parks and feeds them
cook chocolate no don't do it
don't do it it's a feed your dark
chocolate day
don't do it thank you
see royce if we were on discord i could
play the sounder too bad
i guess we could do discord next time
i'm just being lazy
i know i've known you a long time
what is she making a salad in her hair
yes
yes
all right so anyways what they
i'm gonna go ahead and jump in here with
the lice thing no i currently do not
have lice
currently thank god um but
when i was a child i lived in very
poor conditions because you live in very
poor conditions
currently i know when i was a child
they did not give us a clean home
to live in and from the ages of like
four to forty eighteen
i had lice and they would
that's a long time to have lice guys
really name them the lights had [ __ ]
children by the way life's farming
usually if i have an animal or a thing
for that long i name it
he keeps making fun of me for calling
her back the lice got sent off to punk
in college
by the time she was done with her else
after being at my parents
she would kill the lice and then i would
go back home
and get them again so it was a revolving
door
for my poor hair and um
she didn't use the lice treatments
because they didn't always work
you know at the point the the ones that
i was getting back from my sisters were
like
super nice because
it's a song that never ends it goes on
and on my friend star
did she say super lice super lice royce
she's at super lace yeah the next next
coming
super coveted okay get ready
it's from africa
super super less look okay
well jj want to come back back on
tomorrow
i'd sure buddy i ain't got nothing else
to do well you're doing a show today
though right
yeah we're getting some [ __ ] guys
guys check out j.j stoner he's coming up
next on d live dot tv slash jj stoner
head over there right now
i want to give a shout out too please
please the victor von schroom show d
live tv slash victor show
and d lab dot tv slash interesting stuff
two people that are doing
pretty good [ __ ] here lately so go check
them out too they are
and also jj bye
that was my hang up